hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to you
know you can be too old for a lot of
things but you're never too old to be
afraid and our childhoods prompted we
had to put up with clowns and boogie men
and all sorts of ghosts and goblins when
we were grown-up so being the month of
Halloween I decided to take a look back
at the top 11 scariest nostalgic moments
of all time why top 11 because I like to
go one step beyond so get ready to cover
your eyes and hide under the couch this
is the top 11 scariest nostalgic moments
number 11 the Wicked Witch from The
Wizard of Oz for many kids The Wizard of
Oz what's the first movie they ever saw
so naturally wicked wait was the first
villain they ever came across and man
did she freak us out with her green skin
big nose and black attire this wicked
bitch of the north made us all cry out
there's not place like home if you can
believe that this actress actually used
to be a kindergarten teacher Jesus
Christ imagine her greeting you on your
first day of school wanna play ball
number 10 the tunnel scene from Willy
Wonka and the Chocolate Factory
for the most part Willy Wonka is just an
innocent story about a boy who wins a
golden ticket to a factory of wonder and
imagination but someone goes fucking
nuts when it enters the death tunnel
from hell I'm gonna be sick every creepy
image you can imagine pops up here
snakes lizards Gestapo wannabes even a
scene of a chicken getting his head
chopped off
on top of that Wonka reads out loud a
scariest fuck poem and then proceeds to
scream at the top of his lungs and
that's not even the strange part the
strange part is that after this scene of
misery chaos anarchy and death they
never talk about it again
they just go on the merry way like
nothing ever happened man if I was in
that situation even if we got up to the
part with the giant geese I'd be like
dude what the fuck is up with that
tunnel I always thought to myself this
scene would make a lot more sense I have
to write grow up
well I'm grown up now and it still makes
no fucking sense
so what's the deal Wonka what were you
targets direction we are going whoa what
not a speck of light is showing so the
danger must be grown are the fires of
hell of glowing is the grizzly Reaper
mowing
the danger
keep on rowing and they're certainly not
shy
they are
number nine the villain song from
carebears in Wonderland now I know what
you're thinking how can a Care Bears
movie possibly be the least bit scary
well I'm glad you asked there's an
especially gay moment where the villain
of the movie sings a ukulele song about
Wonderland because frankly villains need
more ukulele songs the song itself is
pretty lame when all of a sudden this
happens did you see it did you see it
watch it again in slow motion
holy fuck what is that it looks like
something Charles Manson would shit out
and because the scene goes by so fast it
doesn't just scare us it scares us on a
subconscious level I always said if you
watch Care Bears long enough you'll see
the face of the devil I didn't think you
could actually freeze frame number eight
the Headless Horseman from The Legend of
Sleepy Hollow this is the epitome of a
gothic cartoon it has great atmosphere
creepy visuals and a dark storyline but
it's the Headless Horseman that everyone
remembers with his creepy laugh flaming
pumpkin and of course the absence of a
certain facial feature he gave us all
the willies but this scene in particular
got us all creeped out the Headless
Horseman he had every kid ducking for
cover numbers up the snake from
beetlejuice
even though bilges was a comedy it was
filled with ghastly images that make
kids jump joyfully out of their seats
the creepy is seen being wendy'll juice
transforms into a snake it starts
tossing people around the room when we
come for your night okay
it was big dark creepy and made us all
shit ourselves with fear this snake can
is all rattling under the covers
number six ghostbusters just-just
ghostbusters everything about these
films had creepy written all over and
when your job requires you to do nothing
but hunt down ghosts and goblins that
plague your town chances are you going
to see some scary stuff the two scariest
scenes in particular when Sigourney
Weaver is transformed into a ghostly
demon it might be only one that feels
like this hands copping a feel and the
scene where her baby is taken away by a
spiritual nanny played by Peter McNichol
Peter McNichol is already pretty scary
now imagine him and drag trying to play
a Mary Poppins pedophile from hell and
you've got yourself a pretty nasty image
which I soon scare you the most the
Ghostbuster boobies definitely Raven 9.5
of the scary shadow meter number 5 the
child catcher from Chitty Chitty Bang
Bang
good God was this guy creepy when your
parents said stay away from strangers
with candy this is probably the person
they were talking about he embodied
everything that children imagine bad men
looked like in fact to be honest it's a
little creepier now than he was back
then he looks like one of those guys you
catch on myspace trying to pick up
ten-year-old boys Kiwi whatever reason
he creeps you out he's one bad customer
and my guess is he'll be ringing your
doorbell reading a court required notice
sometime soon number four large march
from pee-wee's big adventure this is a
funny movie whether you're a kid or an
adult however there's one scene that
just comes out of nowhere it involves a
truck driver named Large Marge who
starts telling a ghost story about the
worst accident she's ever seen and when
they finally pulled the drivers body
from the twisted burning wreck
it looked like this what the hell was
that she's just telling a story all the
Sims I mean it just comes out of nowhere
and catches everybody off guard even the
adults we find out later that the Large
Marge that peewee was riding with what's
actually
Oh at least I don't have to see that
sequence again can we cut to a less
frightening part of the movie huh
number three judge doom from Who Framed
Roger Rabbit everything about this movie
kicks ass and the villain is no
exception
he's tall he's dark he's Christopher
Lloyd right on the money the best scenes
though come at the very end when he
transforms into a half man half tuned
psychopath and you could count the
bricks we shit after seeing the scene if
Stephen King did a biography on Mickey
Mouse my guess is he probably looks
something like this
Judge dude he's not bad he's just gone
that way number two the clown from
poltergeist this is bad before the pg-13
rating existed so lots of kids usually
flooded to PG rated scary films like
this one and boy did we regret it
this clown had all of us looking at our
toys funny I used to have a Ninja Turtle
doll that I shot for the most part the
clown does nothing throughout the entire
movie but all the kids are watching it
saying yeah I know you're up to
something okay crap we both know you're
alive
we had to wait the whole entire movie
for this thing to do something and even
though we waited an hour and a half work
we still weren't ready and the number
one scariest nostalgic moment is the
Banshee from Darby O'Gill and the little
people with her ghostly image hideous
complexion and terrifying howl and she
was one of the scariest images that no
kid should ever have to see if you
haven't seen this movie you should it's
pretty good by Disney standards it has
great atmosphere good characters and the
only film you'll ever hear Sean Connery
sings seriously she is my dear my darlin
one my smile and I'm Big Island one and
that's not scary enough for you the
Banshee surely is now the effects in
this movie range from ingenious to
insufferable and the banshee is no
exception
most of the time she moves very
gracefully other times she can't moves
like a go-kart
in fact she's not even onscreen for very
long the rest of the scene focuses on
the death coat which is pretty damn
creepy too but the eerie presence of the
Banshee that gets our blood boiling even
to this day in fact there's one scene at
the end that still continues to scare
the shit out of me even to this date in
fact I usually end up running out of the
room screaming I'm so terrified I don't
even get to finish the rest of the scene
but not today today
see how it's Halloween I'm gonna stand
up for myself
confront my fears and I am gonna watch
this scene all the way through
there's a creepy howling outside there
he goes about to open the door here it
comes